From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History
and Culture.
Today is June 26, 2016.
This is David Cline from the History Department at Virginia Tech and also working with the
Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill.
We are working on the Civil Rights History Project today of the Library of Congress and the
Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Behind the camera we have Guha Shankar from the Library of Congress and John Bishop
of Media Generation and UCLA.
And we are so honored to be at the home of Michael McCarty today in Los Angeles.
And if you could introduce yourself for the tape, we'd appreciate it.
Michael D. McCarty, Storyteller, How about?
We'll run it.
And Michael, where and when were you born?
Chicago, Illinois, September 7th, 1950.
Okay.
Fantastic.
So let's start with your childhood and your family and tell us a little bit about your
people and where you came up.
I grew up in a West Side of Chicago.
I was born in the South Side.
We moved to the West Side when I was about three years old.
And the greatest influence in my life, I like to say, is my mom.
I am a readaholic because of my mom.
I can remember my mom reading me and telling me stories from the time I was about two years
old.
And we always had books and my mother used to say, if you can read, you can do anything.
And the other thing, interestingly enough that she instilled in me is the idea that if
you saw something wrong, you had an obligation to do something about it or to let something
somebody know who could.
And that would come back to give her a little nip later on in life because I took it to
heart.
So grew up, it was me, my mom and dad.
I have two older brothers and an older sister.
And when I say older, 14, 20, 25 years between me and my siblings, I was a surprise.
My mother used to say she thought she had gas.
So grew up and I went to Catholic schools.
My mother was from Barbados.
And so I went to Saint-Threnda Bar Elementary School, Saint Ignatius College Prep.
On both all on the West Side of Chicago, I was going to be a physicist.
I was a, I love math and science.
And that was my dream, was to be a physicist and to be an astronaut.
I became a revolutionary.
Just a little bit of a D2.
But all behind that idea of my mom, you see something wrong, you should do something
about it.
And we got the newspapers, we got, at one point we got the sun times, the tribune, the daily
news, and the Chicago defender.
So we were well read.
And so I had an awareness of, as the civil rights movement grew and developed, I had an
awareness of it from reading the paper.
Watching the court seeing things on the news, seeing all these activities going on.
But then there's the things that happen to you.
We were put to West Side of Chicago near area of Chicago called Cicero, Illinois, Illinois.
Cicero, Illinois, Illinois is one of those sundown areas.
If you were black, don't have your butt in Cicero, Illinois, Illinois after sundown.
You would be hurt, you could be killed.
And these are things that you grew up knowing.
Yeah, yeah.
Or you sort of knew those things.
And at the same time, as a kid, I remember me and a buddy, we rode our bike.
We had bicycles in Cicero, Illinois, Illinois.
In it, we needed some air and tires or something like that and stopped at a gas station to put
air in the tire.
Next thing you know, there's water.
Somebody's holding us and get us out of the area.
But the incident that was the real kicker for me, I was in a boy scouts.
And as boy scouts, you're trying to get merit badges.
So one day, me and three of my friends, we wanted to get our cycling merit badges.
So we left our area around 13th and Avers, 13th and Pulaski was the major street.
And we were going to ride out past Crestwood, Illinois.
And we figured that would give us the necessary mileage to get our cycling merit badges.
So we're riding, riding, and on our way back, we stopped at this water fountain across
the street from a little, a little league game that was going on.
So one by one, we stopped at a water fountain.
And the last one, and I'm there trying to guzzle all the water in the earth.
And all of a sudden, I become aware of my friends because as each one drinks, they would
ride on.
All of a sudden, I look up and they're waving at me and pointing and yelling.
And I look, the little league game had stopped.
And the stands and the feel had emptied.
And this is an all white scenario.
And they're all running.
And I still have this image of this woman, white woman, couldn't have been much more than
five feet tall, running and calling me everything but a child of God with, I know a brick or
a ball or a bat or something in her hand.
I rode real fast, caught it with my friends past them.
Now the thing that I find interesting, I don't think I ever told my parents about that.
Right?
Because that was the way things were.
And we got away, we went on about a business and life went on.
And then later, I was in high school, maybe sophomore year.
And me and a buddy went to a party on the South Side of Chicago over in the hood.
We walked into this project, a high rise project.
And we walked into this building, passed these guys and we turned the corner where we thought
the elevator was, did it?
Turn around, there's these guys, this gang.
And they proceeded to beat the snot out of us for however long.
They literally beat us until they got tired.
Now at one point, the guys who were kicking my butt, kicked my butt out onto the street.
I guess they wanted some fresh air.
And at one point, the guy is going to shoot me.
Because everybody else is like, they're literally tired.
I'm laying face down the ground, he pulls me up by the, that puts a gun to my head and
pulls the trigger.
And this girl, to my mind an angel, snatched it.
No Johnny, don't do it.
Snatched his hand.
And so he pissed away from me.
And at that point in time, Pistol would be bullet in the head, Pistol would be in the school.
So he tells me to run and I can't run, I can't even stand up, but I crawl real fast.
Not even fast, just crawl away.
My friend is still in the building.
I don't know what's going on with my friend.
I see a police car stopped at a light and I stagger over to the car.
Now at this point, I'm bleeding, I'm starting to swell up and I stagger over to the car
and frantically tell him what's happened.
And he looks at me and says, so, white car.
So I get into the police car because this is what's supposed to happen.
He's supposed to help me.
And I tell him where to go and he goes, pulls up a front of the building and tells me to
get out of the car and go into the building and find my friend.
Meanwhile the remnants of the gang are sitting outside the building.
They see me.
They get up and they're coming to the police car to extract me and finish what they started.
I said, look, arrest me, take me away from here.
So he took me to the local police station, which was only a block of two ways I recall.
So I'm thinking this is an adoration.
So I go into the police station and I never even get a chance to say anything.
Now I'm really swelling up.
And the cops all white start laughing when I walk in.
Now my friend had managed to get in somebody's apartment and he called his mom and we met
up at the police station and went to the hospital and he got stitches and stuff like that.
That was my personal wake up call.
And then I became involved in NAACP Youth Council.
Me and my buddy Tyler, we started a black student organization to say,
because Saint Ignatius is like this very prestigious college prep.
95% white on Roosevelt Road in the black community right across from some projects.
But there was no dynamic.
There was no interaction.
And was your street in neighborhood, actually, African American?
All black.
All black, by the way.
So and then you go to school during the day of this totally different environment.
Yeah, totally different environment, totally different environment.
And it's having its own issues that we have to deal with.
Because a lot of the hostility comes is because people don't have familiarity and people react
based on stereotypes.
And that was the kind of thing that we were constantly confronting.
Has Saint Ignatius ever had a Black Student Club?
No.
How did they react when you wanted to do this?
Well, actually, it's interesting.
At first, there was interest because, you know, Jesuits have a history of raising, raising
and cane within the church and fighting for and starting the Mexican revolution of
1810, Miguel Hidalgo y Costilla.
As I think he was a Jesuit that helped kick that off.
And I know there were other Jesuits involved.
So one of the things they arranged, the school arranged, there was a panel.
It would be two or three black guys and one white guy sometime.
And we would go to other Catholic schools in the area and have discussions about race
relations.
So initially, you know, it was supported to a degree.
And then what are the years here that's been passed over?
Let's see, I started.
I was (at) Ignatius from '65 until I got kicked out in March of '69.
That would have been my senior year.
But that's a good story.
I'll cover.
We'll come back to that.
So this is taking place.
So 65, 66 was my freshman year.
So 66, 67 is when we started this organization there about.
And we would have meetings.
We would have discussions.
We would read books and what have you.
And then as was happening at that time, black student organizations in schools, high schools
and colleges had a list of demands.
And we wanted black studies.
Black history at that time was Booker T. Washington and slavery and not even then Harriet Tubman
so much.
But it was very, that was it.
So we wanted black studies.
We wanted outreach community.
We wanted more minority students in the school.
So if we submit our little list of demands, they basically said, get out of here.
So we organized a walk out.
And this was a big thing at the school because this is a school where judges and folks sent
their kids.
So it was a big to do.
So we let this walk out.
And the day of the walk out, there was press.
My mother found out about this on the news that evening.
I came home.
Fortunately, my father worked the graveyard shift.
He wasn't home.
Otherwise, we might not be having this conversation now.
So I came home and my mother was sitting there with my brother and one of my brothers and
my sister crying because she just seen this and she knew there are consequences.
Because it caused more to go to this high school than to some of the local colleges.
And they had invested a lot.
I was going to be the first one of my family to go to college.
And I come in right on.
And my brother decided to fill in for my dad and he burst into the room.
He was going to kick my butt and I started talking until he listened.
I had done what my mother had taught me to do.
But in time, she and my father both came to understand that.
So the next day, we went back to the school and we were informed.
My father took me to school and we were informed by myself and Tyler.
We had been expelled from the school.
And that was the end of my high school career.
Now I'm going to just sort of, here's the thing.
It's an amazing story.
We went on where our lives.
I became, but we both became members of the Black Panther Party.
And eventually, after the party, he works for unions.
I did a variety of things.
30 odd years later, we get contacted by one of our classmates, Greg Myers.
And he said, Mac, we're going to get the school to apologize and give you your high school diploma.
And 39 years later, that's exactly what happened.
He had put together this movement, reaching out to just about every Black student who had
ever gone to the school that was still alive.
And the school apologized and gave us a high school diploma.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
What was really cute is that, did you go back to get it?
Yeah, they flew us in.
They flew us in.
They had a big event over 200 people.
They had it at the school.
We got accommodations from the mayor and two members of the U.S. Congress.
But the thing that I find the cutest is one of Greg's granddaughter had to be about
five years old set.
Greg's granddaughter, how come it take you so long?
Get your diploma.
And you get a good story.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's amazing.
I wanted to ask about, because those times in Chicago, where you, I mean, you guys were
in school, but were you aware of King coming to town and organizing?
Oh, yeah.
Really?
Okay.
When he came, he stayed around the corner.
In fact, my buddy Tyler, he got to see him.
Got to see him, because he was right across from Douglas Park.
He was on Hamlin.
He stayed on Hamlin.
And right across from Douglas Park and Gary was walking from the park towards his house.
And Dr. King was talking out the windows to some of his staff.
And he looked up and said, good morning, Dr. King.
Good morning, young man.
It was just, yeah.
Yeah.
And I remember, I actually do a story about it, how King said, I have dealt with racism
throughout the South.
And I ain't seen nothing like racism in Chicago.
You know, there was a priest who taught racism from the pulpit over in Mayor Daley's
neighborhood.
I can't remember his name, but I have it somewhere.
In fact, because I remember while we were in high school, one summer, we had this job,
and we were going to the, who were in Bridgeport, knocking on doors, trying to sell something.
Somebody didn't like us.
So we're doing this.
We get endorsed land on our face and what have you.
And then one of our white classmates, this is all through Ignatius.
One of our white classes marked classmates.
He says, come on.
He drives up.
Come on, come on.
Y'all getting the car.
Because he had overheard this group of white folks saying they're going to ground us up
and do us bodily harm.
Yeah.
That was our last date doing that job.
Yeah, Chicago was still considered the most segregated city on planet earth.
Very much so.
Yeah.
I mean, do you remember there being a change of any kind when King and those folks came
in or there being talk about it or?
Oh, I remember.
Yeah, yeah.
There was with I remember that before the demonstration, he was going to be a march.
Before the march began, King was hit upside the head with a brick.
Before the march began and the level of violence, the level of animosity, he said, he, I mean,
he'd been holed down.
He'd been dealing with the Klan in the South.
You say, I ain't seen nothing like this.
Oh, Chicago.
So tell me about it.
So you got kicked out of high school.
Mm-hmm.
What next?
Well, then I became a full-time member of the Illinois chapter of the Black Panther Party.
And when had you first come in contact with the Black Panther Party?
Well, I'd said I read.
And so in, you see, the Party formed in October of 1966.
And it was, I think, around 67 that they went to the Sacramento Capitol to protest the law,
67-68.
They went to protest the law that they had been using to carry.
And that was in the news.
I mean, that was an amazing thing.
The pictures of them standing on the Capitol steps with their weapons and the fact that
they were patrolling the police with their guns and with their law books.
All right.
So, and I read ramparts.
I read ramparts magazine.
Among everything I was putting in addition to Ebony and Jet.
I read ramparts and other magazines and newspapers that dealt with the social dealing with social
injustice.
So I had a great awareness of the existence of the Black Panther Party and what they were
doing out there.
And then when they came to Chicago in October, October, November of 1968, I got the word
that there was an office, 2350 W. Madison Street, right in the corner of Western Madison.
I be lying there for the political education class to find out about the party.
And a guy I knew, a friend of mine, I used to run track when I was in high school.
And this guy, Billy "Che" Brooks, who was the Deputy Minister of Education, he ran track
for Marshall.
That's how I knew him.
And when I arrived at the office, there he was.
And so I became a part of the education cadre, which was quite apropos.
We talked to political education classes.
We read.
We discuss.
We, there was a reading list.
Everybody had to read.
But we had to read everything on a reading list.
And we discussed, have these discussions.
And then we would leave these political education classes.
We would sometimes give talks.
There were times when Fred would send me in his place to a debate or to give a speech,
which was more than a notion because Fred was a phenomenal, phenomenal speaker and a
leader.
So those were some of the tasks that I became involved in when I was in the party.
And when you're talking about Fred, you're talking about Deputy Chairman Fred Hampton,
one of the most amazing, like I said, speakers, a motivator, a leader, and someone who taught
me the true meaning of commitment, totally committed to this.
And I mean Fred was, the thing that was so amazing about Fred, Fred was 21 years old when
he was assassinated.
But Fred was, as they say, an old soul.
I mean, in high school, he had been organizing out in Maywood, Illinois at the various high schools.
The blacks couldn't swim at the pool.
Fred said, okay, we got to do something about this.
That's what he was about.
He was about doing something about things.
And he was also someone who was open to learning new things, taking new approaches.
Friend of mine, when he came to join the Illinois chapter of the Black Panther Party, there's
the stereotype of the Black Panther Party as being an anti-white organization.
No, we were anti-injustice.
And one of the things that made the party dangerous was the idea that we saw beyond this concept
of race and race being a tool that was used to divide people who should be working together.
So my friend came up to join the party and it's like, so give me a gun.
I want to kill some white people.
And Fred said, no, that's not how we do things.
All right.
Here's some literature.
Take a look at this.
And if you're still interested, come back, which he did.
But many people aren't aware of the fact that Fred Hampton and Illinois chapter started
the Original Rainbow Coalition.
Oh, that, we had the Original Rainbow Coalition, the Black Panther Party, the Original Rainbow Coalition, the Young
Patriots.
Now people don't know about this.
The Original Rainbow Coalition had been a Puerto Rican street gang that became political.
The Original Rainbow Coalition Organization were poor Appalachian white folks.
And you can see in American Revolution 2, it's on YouTube, you can see the meeting where
Bob Lee and Hank "Bull" Gaddis, who are our field secretaries, had gone into this community, into
the poor Appalachian white community, to talk to these people about why poor whites and
poor blacks should be working together.
And there was this meeting.
And Bob Lee is talking, and at the end of the meeting, this mic, I can't remember, my
great, Mike Gray was the director.
He interviews this old guy and says, well, what do you think about what the Panther said?
And I paraphrase it like this.
But of them black Panthers going for us, I guess we should support them black Panthers.
And a week later, a week later, Bob Lee was in the area by himself doing some organizing,
and he was stopped and arrested by the police, put it into police car to be taken away.
Original Rainbow Coalition Organization saw what happened.
They saw what happened, and they put the word out.
Before that police car could go, they came and surrounded it.
Women and women and children, white men and women and children, and they made the police
let Bob Lee go.
Poor whites, black folks working together, that was a dangerous thing for the powers to
be.
And that outreach started.
The Original Rainbow Coalition Organization, the Original Rainbow Coalition, there were other groups that became associated with
it.
They started organizing their own Free Free Breakfast for Children Program.
They started having their own political education classes.
They started talking about why we should not be fighting with each other, why we should
be working together.
Oh, that was a dynamic, and that was inspired by Fred.
And why was that threatening to the powers to be?
Divide and Conquer is the oldest tool in the book.
What do you do?
Here you have people that should be working together and COINTELPRO.
All right, COINTELPRO.
So what do you do?
You drop.
You have people drop misinformation.
Oh, oh, so and so.
One of the other things that the Black Panther Party was doing was working with the street
gangs and getting them to stop exploiting the community and it become political.
At the time, the biggest gang in the country, not just Chicago in the country, was the Black
Peace Stone Nation, the Black P. Stone Nation later called the Black P. Stone Nation and Fred and Bobby
Rush had these meetings to try to get them to shift their focus and become political.
The FBI under the COINTELPRO program, all of this is when we didn't know at the time
that William O'Neal, our head of security was the head of security was the FBI plant.
But someone would call the Panthers, write a letter.
Someone would call the Black P. Stone Nation.
Yo, yo, so and so, they're trying to set you up to keep us from doing this working together.
And it almost worked.
All right.
They did not get to the point they would have liked it.
But people got to see, we didn't know this thing was happening, but we knew something was
going on.
All right.
Were there other plants or suspicions that there were others?
So did it kind of work in terms of creating paranoia?
Well, in a manner of speaking, you had to be.
Because once we, it was a given that we would be infiltrated.
It was a given.
But when you started seeing things happen and then all of a sudden that you have these people
who are prodding this.
So a level of justified paranoia was indeed evident.
And that did ultimately have an effect on the party.
And in fact, on the movement in general, I like to make reference to this book, The
Burglary, about the peace activists who broke into the FBI office in media, Pennsylvania,
March 8, 1971.
Because they broke in that night because they knew whether they hoped that that would
allow them ease and getting into the office.
Because everybody would be watching the fight and that indeed was the case.
They are who discovered COINTELPRO in one of the files that they took.
And then we found out all manner of stuff that was going on.
I mean, oh my goodness.
I can't remember her name.
There was an actress here in LA who was the supporter of the party.
She would do fundraisers and what have you.
J. Edgar Hoover ordered the FBI office here in LA to neutralize her.
They started a rumor.
She was pregnant.
She was married.
They started a rumor that the baby wasn't her husband's and the baby died.
The woman committed suicide.
The LA FBI office was compensated for having successfully destroyed this woman's life.
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah.
So that's the kind of thing.
And again, we didn't know.
Like I said, again, we knew but we didn't know.
But our approach was we are going to keep doing positive stuff.
We are going to keep serving the people and helping the people.
Thus the breakfast program, the People's Free Medical Clinics, which J. Edgar Hoover said that the
most dangerous thing we did was the Free Breakfast for Children Program because the government
wasn't feeding any children to that particular point in time.
In fact, the subsequent programs they came were essentially the government saying, okay,
we can't have these pastors showing us out.
We've got to feed them.
Head start.
Yeah.
So what other programs?
So and it is very interesting.
At the 40th anniversary of the Black Panther Party, I went, I was in Oakland and it was a
report by people from other chapters.
And it was very interesting because at the time we were immersed in wherever we were.
All right.
There was the national stuff.
There was the local stuff.
You got the paper.
You read about stuff going on.
But unless you were at some other, you know, visiting some other place, you didn't know
what was going on.
So in Illinois, we had the...